we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p take a
listen to this one hi david i'm a recent
number i recently cancelled my recurring
NPR donation to buy a year membership to
your show i think that was pretty great
to us i want to let you know i really
love yourself for two reasons
one is the rational sober adherence to
truth and reality over partisanship when
it's necessary i really appreciate
hearing hard truths over pleasing lies
or optimistic magical things number two
because of your lack of hyperbole and BS
hmm i feel confident sharing your videos
I know the info is going to be solid and
I won't have to spend time defending the
source really enjoy what you're putting
out man keep it up I love the voicemail
I love the financial support I love the
ideological support and the sharing on
social media support that being said
we're not asking people to cancel NPR to
sign up for the David Pakman show I get
for some people it's one or the other
NPR very important of people who
primarily get news from NPR are much
more informed than people who primarily
get used from many other sources so we
love NPR we love our supporters we've
got a great bonus show for you today I
have a crazy story from the weekend
involving the police okay I'm not gonna
say more I will tell it on today's bonus
show